et puis souvenez-vous c'était il y a
bientôt un an l'agression d'un dentiste
à Tours le 17 octobre dernier j'accepte
dentiste à Tours reçoit une dizaine de
coups de couteau un ancien patient
l'accuse de lui avoir mis une protection
en plastique dans la bouche qui la
confondu avec un préservatif après
plusieurs mois d'arrêt le praticien se
sent prêt à officiel à nouveau depuis
quelques semaines il a retrouvé sa
patientèle Hélène chapelet la rencontre
docteur kxm Sandrine un petit mot pour
vous soutenir dans le pré que vous venez
de subir c'est un serpentier de guérison
prenez bien soin de vous dans cette
pochette bleue des dizaines de messages
de soutien reçu de la part de collègues
ou de patients dis-moi après avoir été
violemment attaqué au couteau dans son
cabinet par l'un de ses patients le
docteur Seb a repris son activité
[Musique]
d'attendre le retour du chirurgien elle
n'a consulté personne d'autre en son
absence
beaucoup de gens m'ont dit mais va avoir
un autre médecin non non j'attends
j'attends il va bien revenir et voilà
mais je suis contente maintenant que ce
soit ce soit terminé tout ce que je lui
souhaite on est content de le retrouver
parce que pour deux raisons la première
c'est que on voit que ça prouve qu'il va
bien et la deuxième on est content de
retrouver notre notre dentiste
le 17 octobre prochain cela fera un an
que le dentiste tourangeau a frôlé la
mort il a reçu une dizaine de coups de
couteau de la part d'un patient qui a
confondu un doigtier avec un préservatif
de ce qu'elle physique gravés dans la
chair du professionnel
s donc ils sont visibles même des fois
je vois les le regard des patients qui
regardent ma main pendant que je
travaille donc c'est une plaie qui
disperrait jamais
psychologiquement ça va mieux puisque je
suis là et j'ai repris à temps plein
j'avais une petite angoisse de retrouver
déjà les lieux et puis
je me demandais si j'allais retrouver
mes repères et puis en fait au bout
d'une demi-journée tout est rentré dans
l'ordre
en 2021 19 328 signalements ont été
enregistrés auprès de l'Observatoire
national des violences en milieu de
santé aucune donnée n'existe pour le
secteur dentaire